[Music]
in X's envy news submitted by geo is the
best Oh Joe Joe geo geo nacho whoa look
at all that shade no I thought it was
Joe well she could have like one out of
a thousand it's good yeah I'll take it
I'm [ __ ] desperate oh there it is
jealous ex-boyfriend accused of shooting
four people at a car wash has now been
pronounced dead we can tell one more
times I missed it off a jealous
ex-boyfriend accused of shooting four
people at a car wash has now been
pronounced dead oh my stop it's
murder-suicide there's some positive in
that is that a car wash so they could
clean up really nice get that business
she chose a car wash
maybe the new boyfriend works there oh I
never thought of that that's a that's a
great place if you're a hitman to kill
somebody if they're in the car wash
there's a much easier than that those
are stuck in the car well in the [ __ ]
car and they can't get out you know it's
one of those auto car wash you know
those movies I love the sound that they
put in on even though it's real when the
bullets go through like glass into the
car - I love it love that sound
but I also love the silencers now
because it sounds nothing like that look
it doesn't sound like that in real life
this is not like you really these are
all a silencer yeah that's exactly right
nice shot I shot so you can't even hear
it anymore it's just somebody shushing
Shh the shooter is he a military guy not
that I know of but he was just a major
gun enthusiast I just see military guys
in the background yeah yeah I would have
assumed the same well maybe yeah what
they didn't mention that when they're
away he's holding it though honestly
that looks like family day in the Marine
Corps and he looks like a giant fanboy
so family day is
your unit you bring all your family and
you get to like you don't break all
kinds of like stereotypes or whatever
and you make a connection between
civilians and military and he looks like
someone's friend and he's like oh my god
yeah take a picture of me holding the
gun and he's like yeah so he went to a
car wash car wash
and one of those like self car wash ones
and the ones that you pull up you wash
your own car so it's a gas station the
coins kind
yeah the coin kind both of my favorite
self-serve carwash crime it doesn't do a
good job but it's so relaxing I don't
know why I pictured you in like a white
tank top done this way [ __ ] daisy
dukes a lot of Sun Sun yeah think of
them in a sexy way you would consider
that sexy without your shot there's
nothing that you directors don't you do
yourself just say you do one the k-town
oh yeah the 24-hour time with a little
brush yeah not the one with the rainbow
website it's the one with the precious
sprayer you
he went to this carwash he was waiting
there in the early hours in the morning
it seems to be about 3:00 a.m. and then
that's when his ex-girlfriend shows up
with her new boyfriend who's married did
he know that they were gonna be there in
the a.m. because that's the place they
have sex at it seems like like police
are trying to piece it together and it
seems like based off of phone records
the group of friends we're gonna meet up
there and he somehow knew that what a
[ __ ] weird meetup place so then
because there were people do that man
ever the grocery store ain't like
because you gotta get kitty litter or
some weird [ __ ] at like 1:00 in the
morning like me and you see a bunch of
people like at the grocery store hanging
out in the parking lot hang out 1993 geo
we do this every time we eat yeah but we
look we talked about we agent exactly
mmm I thought all agents do that yeah
but I said but he's saying other people
not just
do that 1993 all right all right get off
my back get off my baby hanging at the
grocery store they're hanging out the
restaurant next to the grocery store and
that's why they just happened to be
there for four hours es always CVS Oh a
7-eleven CVS yes right
always grocery store for some reason
yeah we should maybe investigate this
yeah so Timothy was waiting there for
all these people to arrive at the
carwash he was armed with an ar-15
semiautomatic rifle a 9-millimeter
handgun and possessed a 308 rifle I
don't know I don't know I don't know
what these look like maybe that one's
big and that one's small and no matter
how big they are
you'll have to pull each each straight I
don't know the meter is small again it's
pistol okay I'm 308 usually a bigger
rifle
oh really you also wore body armor what
does that mean what a body armor carrier
without the ballistic pants a flak
jacket what if he wears it that's like a
bulletproof vest without the bullet the
best 40 armor without the paddles can
still stop and I know okay why cuz
there's Kevlar Kevlar oh uh he's more
t-shirt is what they should have said
yeah he wore it best you were a badass
t-shirt that's right what you should
have said yeah and so he goes up hands
up shooting his ex-girlfriend and her
new boyfriend
and also there was uh two other victims
that died inside of their car with these
the first two victims I mentioned they
died outside of the car did he speak
using a shot out why did he wear maybe
he did just in case their friends were
armed or whatever he's the kind of guy
who's a guy plan ahead yeah what where
was this in Pennsylvania who so there
was some Quakers around or what do they
know the Amish Thomas right is it the
Amish in Pennsylvania I'm not you think
so hardly but this is his ex-girlfriend
which one Chelsea said she has a
snapchat come on out of all the photos
they had to get the snapchat the kiddie
one yeah and then this is the guy that
she was fabulous
a really good standing comedian I think
yeah that that looks like like a
Halloween picture like he's he's being
what's his name the guy that jacked off
in a movie theater pee-wee Herman yeah
William Porter filled Friday at flappers
age and these are the other two friends
that were also killed
there was a lucky survivor she was
hiding in the back seat and she only got
injured from the glass because he was
one of them as a shield like a smart
person
so these cats were all friends yeah and
so he just wanted to kill the prince too
just for funsies and they all died or
these more people died he shot himself
in the head he was put on life support
but now it's been reported that he died
why did he want a vest he's gonna shoot
himself when it's not covered yeah he's
obviously crazy you can't use logic you
can't ask logical question that did a
logical [ __ ] yeah that's so interesting
he showed up with elbow pads on for no
reason he shoots himself in there yeah
and they're all so young to like William
porterfield's he's 27 really yeah I know
yeah I'm so shocked by these numbers
right now Stan of Ages you a lot all
right the guy with the rifle they said
he was 28 I was like solid 41 very dude
27 the ex-girlfriends 25 and then the
girlfriend the friend but the girl is 23
and then the guy that died yeah they all
look like they have kids that are yeah
Chelsea looks the youngest oh yeah
that's true I think Courtney looks young
Courtney yeah she looks young too
yes Chelsea also looks Japanese or
something yeah there's something with
the filter the folks are kind of messed
it all up
they're they're they're all they're all
dead oh that's uh I've never had an
annexe that was that crazy about me well
that makes sense maybe because you're
the crazy ex because you're the crazy
oh wait but I would break up with them
how would I why would I be yeah that's
why you're crazy
you'll break up with ever that's in the
back yeah get the [ __ ] out of my house
I'd call me right after like I'm
breaking up with you and as soon as
they're in the car I miss you
how would you break up with somebody now
or how I did it before no I don't want
to hear about your evolved version now
you [ __ ] Pokemon yeah how would you
break up with part now break up with
part now yeah but you guys aren't
married and you guys been together for
like three months we don't have a kid
have a kid you're Mary didn't you have a
kid go oh yeah you are married we do
have a kid oh yeah
I wouldn't bite what a breakup now Mike
is like two and you got another one way
to go no stop it is to their shared
circumstance are too [ __ ] up David I'm
going with yours
we're just boyfriend/girlfriend no tyka
we've been going out for how long does
it [ __ ] matter ice all right doesn't
matter doesn't matter
this is this a hard thing and I don't
love them anymore right yeah I would now
I would probably say hey we need to talk
and then no no don't I don't care about
your reasonable [ __ ] didn't want to hear
the dirty [ __ ] just know if you're
breaking up with him I don't want to
hear you recreate it just do it now okay
and his name his name is Chun il's song
shan l saw no he says when you were 22
years old
Oh 22 so they changed for you who we've
been asking no he said now cuz you don't
want that welcome oh he kept saying he
doesn't want your [ __ ] so my [ __ ]
was [ __ ] up cuz it was a slow slow
kill like he was [ __ ] up so it wasn't
like a like the what like I've been
feeling [ __ ] up and I'm gonna be okay
you know what you talk too much I'll
break the with you
[Laughter]
I would just be a [ __ ] where I wanted
him to break up with me let go he just
dumped you get the [ __ ] out of here dude
get over it dude you're [ __ ] crazy
just took too [ __ ] long so here to do
it anyways crazy he's old I'm Belgian
corset bucket that mean he was that bad
though because she kept trying to like
well now it's different now it's
different yeah I [ __ ] up ya know but
then I did we just be like here you know
what it's not working out we gotta break
up and it'd be really cool and they
would be like not so normal
I wish girls broke up with me like that
how you reasonable yeah is it yeah
that's straight up that's what guys want
then they would say like why like that
just it's not working like that's it
okay is it the thing that thing I'm just
done and you know what guys do after
that yeah this girl's a jack of Shame
girls think that that's cold but it's
not guys actually wanna direct yeah I
just dated really immature guys cuz then
they'd get the text I'd get the phone
call and they're showing up at my work
that's quite because maybe you didn't
give them signs and you cut them off out
of nowhere
that's like he made he made you dinner
and [ __ ] he got you a puppy but like hey
by the way get the [ __ ] out buster yeah
thanks to the puppy [ __ ] yeah I was
a [ __ ] dude I'd be like you'll be like
I'd be mean to them so that they would
break up with me cuz I wanted to be a
[ __ ] but it was too nice I couldn't
that's why they kept staying with you
and that's why five years later but look
at it's awesome because you have a
beautiful boy named Isaac yeah and you
have a perfect hairless husband watches
many well extend a weekend with every
needs berry hair oh yeah he's like a
dolphin a Chinese ghost appears tell you
he's a dolphin with a little bit of
wiggle know what you guys talk well yeah
we were on our radios retreat yeah yeah
we rolled up movie script yeah it's
right here these [ __ ] are so stupid
[Music]